thank you
[Music]
so there's this coder her name's
Michelle Wang and she developed a really
cool
really well a female coder is always
funny to me yeah that's true
yeah of course I thought just because I
said Wang
all right
um she took um she made this really
interesting AI program that not only did
she create it but she also put the
instructions so we could make it
ourselves if we wanted wow open source
yeah it's um she took 10 years of her
own diary entries from when she was a
kid and she fed it into this machine
that created a simulation that allows
her to text chat with her younger self
what the what so it's like your younger
self will use the information from her
diary to formulate answers in the style
of speaking that she was okay Tom Riddle
what's a diary and what's a journal yeah
good question it's it's like uh it's
gender it's like Nosotros no satras
those sat traps
I failed Spanish four times so that
makes sense can we see what the
difference is I never knew what the
difference journal in a diary yeah I'll
show you right now yeah a journal is
something that like a therapist will
recommend you do in order to log things
get things out of your mind a diary
something that like a a wimp and a [__]
will do in order to [__] cope with
[__] don't make fun of my [__] dude you
have diary I had a diary in elementary
school they get they made you make your
own diary with [__] like construction
paper and every day it was like you have
to start with dear diary wait isn't
Journal like more observational and
diary is more from a personal
perspective don't pretend like you have
the answer this whole time and then
suddenly just bring it out when people
I've just been thinking about it that's
fine with the question mark yeah I've
been thinking about is that what it is
yeah that's exactly what I told you
earlier on the camera like this happened
whatever whatever but it's not
necessarily your own feelings that
you're injecting but diary is like this
is how I feel about what happened you
know I think it's up to the person who's
writing in it there you go this is a
diary kind of the most common oh okay I
see that with the lock and the journal
no that looks like a sensitive Journal
no that's a diary it's pink journals
aren't composite notebooks this is a
[__] Journal whoa whoa
okay I missed those man I'm gonna trap
you can do whatever you want you can
shoot them with a gun you have slots for
your pen and they even have a built-in
clipboard on the inside yeah protective
cover I couldn't afford that so I only
had peachy folders that were giving out
for free I remember those two yeah cool
I think when did any of you guys ever
keep a journal when you were younger I
tried to I did for like uh nine days
after the movie Harriet the spot I came
out and then I got bored are you aboard
of your own journaling yeah you know who
you know who made it cool
um Doogie Howser into the show he would
write lessons so I actually tried to I'm
gonna try to like write a couple things
then after like two of them I was like
this is like a boy Hauser made something
cool I thought it was pretty cool did
you really think Doogie Allison was a
character is cool
yeah the kid doctor yeah that's [__]
cool man let's jump him after 15.
[__] this guy up
sorry we have to jump up man Duke house
was cool dude
[Laughter]
you're my [__] hero man [__]
this guy was cool kind of cool imagine
the bad video yeah
wow
[Laughter]
you ain't nothing he went bad you ain't
bad but yeah that's um the crazy thing
about a journal is like I remember when
I was doing a journal when I was really
young it was very databased and
informational it's like here's what
happened today but it wasn't so much how
I felt it was like a police report yeah
try to ground me
[Laughter]
I'm describing people to myself
sketching them yeah but then my sister's
diary which like I would find
occasionally go oh it's like more about
how she feels about things yeah the
current state of her life I would read
my sister's Diaries too and they
wouldn't know and I'd be like was it
anything cool no no Intel you'd be like
Nick is a [__] idiot I hate my
brother he's a he's I know you're
[__] reading this right now you son
of a [__] or it's not one of those
things where they have a crush on a guy
named like Sam or something like that so
they write like Sam a thousand times in
a row yeah my sisters were so boring I
was like how do I get my massive titties
in this little top and I'm like oh my
God good God a break oh you know what
you know what's one real thing I did
write about I think when I was like 11
there was like I did have a journal
entry that where I was struggling
between which girl do I like and the
difference was that one of them was like
really pretty and the other one was just
[__] hilarious oh those were like the
two things that I was torn between well
I mean this was obvious yeah this is
obvious this is obvious yeah let's not
say let's say I'll say the funny one oh
of course not at 11. I got better jokes
than her I can make myself laugh can't
make yourself pretty though yeah that's
true
no one else kept a journal or Anthony
diary or anything I would have a journal
I have a journal still that I haven't
written in for a long time but I still
have it I said Nikki does it every
[__] day and she has like I mean I
don't know when we're moving I have to
move like seven boxes of journals is it
scheduled it's like my morning feel my
night theme or it's just 20 minutes
morning oh I had a lot um I do have a
journal actually I stopped writing in it
because
um
I wanted to see and log in I was waking
up with um these anxiety attacks it
would just come out of nowhere huh and I
would just be like three in the morning
and it's just like I feel like I'm being
chased or whatever I can't go back to
sleep and I would have them
um at different times like like out of
nowhere for no reason like I'm having a
blast with you guys go to sleep and I'll
just wake up like [__] and I'm like oh
[__] I'm at home I'm okay
because I drew out a calendar and I
wrote down every day like what happened
how's my mood today like what are the
things I'm eating like I just wanted to
get down to the bottom of it yeah is it
is it I'm working out or whatever so
then I did that and I logged it in and
and in those in between pages I would
just go off on like a mental dump
and I think like whatever was trapped in
my head in the morning like or whether
whether it be 3 A.M or whatever when
that I wake up in a [__] panic I
can't go back to sleep so I just write
and I just write write whatever it is
it's on my head
and it could be as stupid as like
um you know what form of martial art is
the real one or like something stupid
right like it doesn't [__] matter
which one is
anxiety attacks like [__] what's the
real martial art
super unrelated
things that shouldn't bother a human
being or it would be like like legit
like man I actually have it on my
backpack I carry with me everywhere and
then as soon as
um
the crypto crash went down I was getting
them every [__] day and then
um I wrote it I was writing down
specifically what was going on
and then with joombie building up in
Hawaii and then I think like once
everything started to get to this point
where I have control like I could build
my business I can do things
um then it just all disappeared wow but
I do get them periodically in my life
reassume control I think that's what it
was because you were slipping because
the Calamity of other things not out of
your control and until journaling or
whatever felt like it was the only thing
I can brain dump and like centralize
whatever was going on raindrop is a
really good I've done that with
um dreams because you ever wake up
um after having a dream and gone like
that dream was brilliant yeah like where
like it's like man that was like a
murder mystery but it made so much sense
it's like every little piece of it was
like so interesting you could never
think of that awake exactly and then um
so I so I started to
um keep my you know phone next to me
with the notes open and [__] and then
I'd wake up and I'd write it down and
then I'd read the next day I'm like oh
no you think it makes sense but it's
actually [__] sucks it's just that
you woke up and you're like whoa that
was profound blah blah but no when you
write it down and then you're just in
that moment it seems like it but then
the next day you're like what the [__]
was I talking your understanding of it
is that it's a hit exactly yeah I think
it's a smash exactly the funny thing is
uh did you guys ever have zanga back in
the day I never had a saying that no I
think it was like the journal kind of
like predating most social media it
probably was too many words yeah yeah
any pictures back then yeah there was a
thing called a Wayback machine it's a
website all the old websites that don't
exist anymore Wayback machine and then
like I went to see if my old Zango was
still up how did you even remember way
back you have to remember your actual
URL and then check and then it'll it'll
maybe at some point in time have logged
it and it did have it and the only thing
on there is uh on my actual account in
2003 I remembered I deleted all of my
other I used to write a shitload of
stuff on here and I remember I privated
everything so I'll never see it again
but there was one thing that I left and
it was on September 14 2003 and it's the
entire story of what happened to TJ the
day after it happened
whoa
and I totally [__] forgot that I
wrote this and then like I read it over
and I was like holy [__] that's my day
after understanding of like exactly what
went down that's crazy does it give you
Goosebumps reading yeah it's creepy as
[__] because I'm also talking in a total
different way it's like holy [__] like
it really does feel like I'm listening
to a kid from you know like a kid I
barely know the same way that she did
this AI thing and is talking to it it's
probably it she said it gave her this
like really like kind of like an out of
this world feeling because it's like you
think you should know this person but
you the growth between then and now is
so great and I think it's greater than
anyone can really like comprehend but
when you're faced with like speaking to
or um listening to that person and the
thing that you remember in a different
way now it really you see the distance
like it's [__] huge yeah I'll whoop
the [__] out of my younger self why slap
his ass tell him to grow up a little bit
better a little bit quicker yeah a
little bit better like why the [__] do
you want to dance you dumbass that's the
thing you would change tell them to do
not dance I'd probably be like don't get
in there with barjo the battle Mike's
song at the at the college party no just
do that that one was still a good one
my journal and what I have is in this
little gray notebook that was given to
me a long time ago um but it was because
you know I was constantly traveling and
teaching and Performing or judging
showcases right you know the whole
[__] Dance World thing we're going
and oftentimes you're by yourself right
so like the the interesting thing that
you realize is when you do like
phenomenal things when you like
experience amazing experiences and then
you don't have like a very very close
friend that you can like debrief with or
bring that shared experience back with
even when you go home you try to explain
to your significant other explaining and
recounting something is never the same
nah yeah you know what I mean and so no
matter what there's a language that it
just doesn't
you just can't get spoken and sometimes
the only way that you feel that you can
hold on to something is writing whatever
it is down so I started logging and
[__] into them though yeah yeah
that's true true open up about that and
they don't usually appreciate when you
talk about your groupie conquests yeah I
didn't log those things I wasn't as
successful as you Joe at [__] all my
groupies not not groupies fans we don't
like it at the Hannah was like like she
thought it was entertaining girlfriends
don't like it when you talk about when
when you have sex yeah so these were
wholesome great stories that I wanted to
hold on to myself in case I got like
Dementia or Alzheimer's or something
like that but what about the groupies
you [__]
like I said Growers don't like it you
ever do like uh
would you prefer riding it or would you
prefer like doing a voice note or even
recording your own self like I don't
like hearing myself I don't want to hear
myself talking which is probably why I
don't watch the show you know what's the
crazy thing about memory so our memory
is so [__] wild right that when you
remember when you remember something
about your past you're remembering the
last time you thought about that memory
oh [__] isn't that wild yeah
foreign
[Music]